ce
club et il est mort ce mauvais pas
[Musique]
il est à moi
est à moi
les suspects s'échappe par la seine à
bord d'une d'une baignoire demandons
renfort je crois qu'on les a semés vous
parler de cela
les gaz à fond thaçi trop jeune pour le
prix sont personne n'ira en prison oui à
me regarder devant leur cave
[Musique]
car et votre paie trois ans
comme
le sprint final est lancé le grand
champion espagnol est talonné par le
peloton va dire enfin triomphé en
remportant la course
[Musique]
bravo champion tu vas enfin gagner mais
quel prix non mais non au nom
batteuse d'affaires voiture ce mur
l'explorateur et la table d'émeraude au
cinéma le 24 août et regarde ça jeff
qu'est ce que ça fait au mexique
un sarcophage égyptien
maintenant tout va
est-ce que ça va très bien j'ai vraiment
aucun risque
tu es viré
elle revient
pour à la case départ meta est mauvais
sens sur la paire avec de nouveaux amis
amon
ramona non il y à des pauses à respecter
pour de nouvelles aventures
quelle équipe de choc qu'est ce que tu
as fait à mona lisa je les corriger
oh non moi quand je suis nerveux j'ai
des gaz
saluée par les deux momies
alors là bravo c'est la môme il a plu
riquiqui que j'ai jamais
tu es maudit ce genre de 7
devient permanent s'il n'est pas de
risque
pat explorateurs et la table d'émeraude
c'est super cool au cinéma le 24 août